well let's turn our attention now to the
press preview and what is making
tomorrow's front pages joining us
tonight are the political editors of the
guardian and the son pippa grabber and
harry cole
and let's see then what's on some of
those front pages for you in the express
pictures the new king with his head
bowed in front of the lake queen's
coffin at today's vigil in edinburgh the
headline
lost in grief for darling mama
the metro remarks on
the king's vigil
and the sun has an identical headline
likewise the eye
says vigil for a mother
the male calls it a silent vigil for a
queen and a mother
and that guard of honour is the main
focus for the telegraph as well
and here's the mirror their headline
we will watch over you
and the times opts for an exterior shot
of today's proceedings in edinburgh
describing the royal family as united in
grief
according to the star people who cue to
pay their respects to her majesty on the
funeral routes here in london could be
made to wait for up to 30 hours
and away from royal matas the guardian
reports that an emergency budget is
expected at the end of next week to lay
out more details of how the government
plans to avoid
winter energy crisis
and the financial times hears that the
new chancellor quasi quatting is poised
to tell the treasury to focus entirely
on growing the uk
economy
well let's speak then to pippa carrera
and harry cole now we featured uh both
of your papers there so let's start
harry with yours the sun and it is the
king's vigil
yeah i think it's really interesting to
note that all the papers seem to be now
moving towards
instead of putting the late queen on the
front it is the
it is the king it's looking to the
future it is entirely sort of
charles led coverage now obviously you
know those those initial days of
mourning papers had you know
years almost to prepare
features and magazines and pull-outs and
now we're really into sort of live news
and i think it's it's interesting and
then you know
pipper and i will look at these things
in much more detail than most punters
but it really is a picture-led
uh story now the the grief etched on the
king's face there the pictures of the
crowds um
these the whole pages of the newspapers
are not just the tabloids which are
traditionally picture-led but the broad
sheets the front page of the ft for
example big big pictures you're seeing
now and
they kind of say it all um
this is like everything a moment we've
all prepared for
in our in the back of our minds but
we'll never be able to sort of escape
those really incredibly stark images
that just keep getting sort of always
more emotional as the days go on
and pippa yeah i mean it is quite
astonishing to hear we heard it from our
royal commentator alastair bruce that
the uh tradition of um the royal family
members of the roy family themselves
standing vigil over the coffin um dates
back only i mean given the thousands of
years nature or hundreds of years nature
of some of the ceremonial this only
dates back to the 1930s
yeah and it happened um when the queen
mother lay in states senior members of
the royal family then uh prince philip
and and his sons stood at the four
corners of her coffin in westminster
hall which is of course where the queen
will lie in state the lake queen will
lie in states when um her coffin is
brought down from edinburgh
to london tomorrow it shall spend it
will spend the night in buckingham
palace and then we'll move to
westminster hall which is the heart of
the palace of westminster and where
today we saw
the new king
and
his wife's queen concert camilla be
received by the two speakers of the
house of lords and the house of commons
and they
pay tribute to
to his mother and then also
to him
and it was uh you know a ceremony as so
many of these that we've seen with a
military presence with um real sort of
like uh sort of pomp and
there was the music and it was a very
beautiful ceremony in a very ornate
setting but um then obviously you
traveled back up to edinburgh and there
you've got your images of the the
queen's coffin the lake queen's coffin
innocent gels cathedral
on the high street in edinburgh my my
home city and tonight scott's cueing um
right eye and the royal mile by the
looks of things um to pass through to
walk through to pay their respects to
the coffin as well
um so while harry is of course right the
focus is switching to the new king um
there's still this there's still
obviously a nation grieving and
people many people wanting to pay their
respects and uh you know that will
continue over the coming days uh right
up until right up until her funeral next
week
indeed let's uh just take in another of
those front pages as you're saying some
quite remarkable pictures this is on the
telegraph which also focuses
on what was going on what is going on in
singapore's cathedral it is the the
guard of honor in the telegraph
and uh
a different shot but um directly and and
harry
it was this um some people remarking on
it seems slightly strange that um
they're the king and of course
his uh two brothers and sister as well
and other parts of the catapult there
but some then members of the public just
walking past almost looking at them
almost
i mean there's a slight element of
madame two sodes about it
i think it's actually
it's remarkable how you know
how humid it is really you've got you've
got as you say members of the public and
then you've got the grief etched on the
face of charles there but doing his
studio imagine the last place you know
he'd want to be is under the full glare
but he's doing that regardless um in a
in a really strange way and without
standing at all morbid in this um the
fact that the queen died in scotland
i think is
has given edinburgh uh and scotland
an entire part in this ceremony which
they wouldn't have had had the queen
died say sandringham as other monarchs
have or at windsor and in a way i think
it's
i think the the the the family appear to
be
not not using that as a as such but
taking full advantage in a good way to
you know to allow as many people from
different parts of the country to
be part of those proceedings so i think
it's amazing that the king is standing
there in edinburgh and i think it's a
shame actually that tomorrow the
um
the the coffin will be taken on to a
plane and flown to london rather than
the original plans which i understand
were shelved at the beginning of the
pandemic to have the royal train um very
slowly going through parts of the
country where other people in perhaps
the middle of the country would be able
to pay their respects and the way the
people of scotland are turning out
tonight the way that we're expecting
millions of people in the south to turn
out and in london but there is a there's
a feeling perhaps there's almost a
missed opportunity for that for that uh
coffin to be you know sort of taken
slowly so other people in other parts of
the country be able to pay their
respects in the same way but again it's
a it's a sort of moot debate now it's
it's it's set in stone but perhaps on
reflection it could have been done in a
slightly um a slightly useful broader
way and i wonder whether some of the
plans have been dusted down in the last
48 96 hours perhaps underestimated the
number of normal members of the public
that would like to be involved one of
the versions of the plan i saw suggested
that only 40 to 50 000 people a day
would want to to come to westminster
hall this week and that's looking like
it's gonna be out by a factor of at
least five possibly ten
yeah yeah i mean you know well we're
seeing that aren't we perhaps in
microcosm pippa taking place in
edinburgh this very moment as we take
those live shots inside saint gel's
cathedral
just this constant flow of people and we
know it's going to be like that
throughout the night
until they they close the cathedral and
move the coffin
yes that's right and
you know the scale of of interest
and
this desire amongst the scottish people
to come out and
pay their respects i think we'll see
replicated in london um there'll be the
the uh with the queen motherland state
um about 15 years ago in westminster
hall it was open all night and so there
will be the opportunity for people to
to um you know to parade through and uh
and to do that
you know really into the into the wee
hours
um
both there in edinburgh and but also
later on in london and you know i agree
with harry it's a shame that
you know circumstances circumstances of
her death has enabled this opportunity
for the people of scotland to be
involved in all of this in a way that
they would not otherwise have been and
it is a shame that that's not going to
be
that possibility is not going to be
available for
for other parts of other parts of the uk
um although i'm sure a lot of people
will travel or travel to london um
it's uh you know one thing that's really
struck me about all of this is the
planning obviously has been
going on for decades probably given the
late queen's age um and uh there's been
lots of rehearsals harry will know as
well if i've spoken to people in
whitehall about this that they've
frequently rehearsed what would happen
at this moment and here we are seeing
this this great plan um
finally bearing fruit and it does feel
that that um lots of it you know lots of
these eventualities have been considered
to give people these opportunities to
to come out and and sort of share their
share their grief with um
uh share their grief over the queen's
death um with their friends and their
neighbors and their their their
colleagues their um
their fellow their fellow edin
edinburghers and in this instance fellow
scots um
and i think there's a real sort of
collective it feels like a real
collective endeavor doesn't it that um
people whether they're royalists or not
actually it's not even
um
necessarily about how they how they view
the monarchy it's it's also think about
witnessing a moment of history this is a
this is a moment that we've all
anticipated all of our lives um but and
we all knew that it would come at some
point uh but it's incredibly poignant um
and to be able to be granted the the
access i think to a moment like this in
this way i think a lot of people will
you know whatever their views of the
monarchy more widely will want to go and
pay their respects to the queen as a
person and also to like i say to have
that that's the front row seat on
history something that they will be able
to tell their children and grandchildren
in years to come
and uh let's just take a look at the
front of the mail a
similar scene slightly different
headline but on the that issue of of
numbers and when the coffin arrives in
london harry well let's
imagine the numbers we're talking about
you said some of the planning was for
only forty or fifty thousand well one
imagines it's going to be multiplied by
something like a factor of ten
if not more um you know i just look
behind me now i'm
standing outside buckingham palace at
what approaching 11 o'clock and just
this constant stream of people still
being funneled through a very efficient
system being set up here with the
barriers and the one-way systems and
blocking off bits to get things ready
for events over the next few days but
still a constant stream of people coming
to leave flowers inspect the flowers
look at the front gates of buckingham
palace um and we are hearing what
something like
24 hours 30 hours in the queue to see
the coffin in westminster hall
absolutely i mean the
one of my favorite things about the
voxbox is going back to pippa's point
just very quickly about people that you
know might not be might not consider
themselves
monarchists or great advocates of the
royal family of the system but
on sky on bbc or elsewhere but done
interviews where they've said actually i
just felt a need to be here i just
needed to to to be here and in a weird
way some sort of
people are awakening in the they are
monarchists and they are wellness they
just haven't really thought about it in
the way that they the way that those
labels which have been slung around a
little bit over the last few years um as
sort of traditional fuddy-duddy or
old-fashioned and actually it's a sort
of a rejuvenating experience for the
monarchy
in the fact that that seamless
transition of power is something
literally to a wonder to behold and
people want to be close to it so
i think we'll be seeing some
extraordinary scenes over the over the
next 96 hours um some of the plans i've
seen involve
yeah three to five mile queue an average
waiting time of perhaps 12 hours
we'll see wristbands so people will be
able to sort of tag in and tag out
to get some
water to relieve themselves to get food
but you know the expectation is being
you know be careful because you are
going to be queueing through the night
potentially and the the the the
westminster hall will be open 24 hours
uh and i think we're going to really see
some extraordinary extraordinary scenes
obviously behind that there's a massive
security operation
going on um you know we do live in a
troubled world something awful could you
know
touch wood won't happen but thousands of
policemen
have had their leave council have had
their overtime on overtime had their
weekends
you know sorry not a man not many
complaints about that we've got about 1
500 members of the armed forces on
standby um it's going to be you know
there's the british state gearing in
kicking into something we haven't really
seen in london since the olympics
and uh let's just go back to well not
just edinburgh today i want to take in
the metro here if we get this up because
you know there's a lot of discussion
some controversy about those that um
want to make well you know some points
about monarchy um uh
look we interviewed today who'd um
shouted out at uh
shouted out at um the reading of the
proclamation in oxford uh who voted for
him and there's uh one heckler arrested
in edinburgh pippa for calling the duke
of york a sick old man clearly um
freedom of speech is something that uh a
majesty would have supported but there's
this issue of whether it's appropriate
um at this time isn't it and indeed um
at that place
i think there's two separate things here
and we need to be careful not to confuse
them the first is whether it is the
decent or appropriate thing to do to
shout out at a funeral or in a
procession like this when people are
mourning
many people would feel that it's not
appropriate and that actually there
there's a time and a place for this sort
of protest
however um the second aspect of it of
course is that um
we need to be careful not to blur it
with what is legal and what is not and
of course as proponents of free speech
in this country and defenders of free
speech i think there's an ex has to be
an acceptance that you might not
necessarily agree with or like what um
what people are protesting about but uh
they have a right to do it so like i say
there's two very different two very
different uh arguments there we need to
be careful not to cloud them i think
where some concern has arisen has been a
feeling that in some cases not in all of
course the police is slightly
overstepping the mark there was a video
earlier of course in westminster um of a
um
a barrister who was holding a loft a a
blank piece of paper
and was asked to move on by police and
some of this was caught on caught on
camera and then went viral online and
the met the met police uh insisted
tonight have issued a statement saying
that's in the police the sorry that
saying that the public absolutely have a
right to protest during the days
following the death of the queen
um
i think you know most of us would agree
with that that it's that it's obviously
anybody's right to do so but i think
also most people would
i guess
feel that it was um that it was
important to sort of bear in mind um
that while they may have their very
strong almost political views on matters
like this no matter if
they're very strong republicans for
example um that others might be offended
by it and that they need to take into
account whether it's appropriate to do
that but um but like i say there's two
separate issues what's illegal and
what's appropriate um or inappropriate
in this case potentially um shouldn't
really be blurred
yeah and what do you think harry i mean
there's no one denying that people have
the right to express these
sentiments but it's kind of at this time
isn't it yeah there's an issue of
decency i suspect i mean i suspect that
young chap who shouted at andrew on the
royal marvel quite appreciative of the
police getting the hell out of there
pretty quickly because that mob were
looking like they were going to give him
a good old hiding um if the coppers
hadn't have been there with the guy in
westminster as well look those gates you
know don't forget that that was the
exact scene of the westminster terror
attack in 2017 those gates are occupied
and busy uh and live throughout the day
i've made the mistake of standing
outside those gates tried to hail a taxi
and within about eight seconds the cops
were shouting at me and screaming
whistles moving on there's perfectly
places to protest 10 feet away so again
as pepper said there's a difference
between what's legal and what's
appropriate what i would say though is
in the last two or three years
we have seen ridiculous overbearing
policing in this country of free
speeches where were these people that
you know there's lots of lefty mps who
don't like the royal family anyway
jumping on these tiny cases but where
were they when you know an army veteran
was arrested for um for retweeting
lawrence fox because it might have upset
someone where were they and all these
other ridiculous um sort of times the
police have turned up at people's houses
for things they've tweeted and if this
triggers in the long run
perhaps a conversation about the
overbearing public order act of 1986 or
the fact that the police seem to be in
recent times doing more to police free
speech than perhaps some you know
burglaries
for example great let's have that
conversation it's long overdue but can
we just not have it this week let's give
it give it a rest for a few days because
where were you when there's this has
been going on for the last few years
okay well let's talk about something
that would have been happening this week
paper it's you're reporting in your own
paper on
an emergency budget i think they're
going to call it a fiscal event aren't
they um not uh use the the budget word
um but it would have we imagine been
happening this week
but it is going to happen pretty soon
after the funeral
yes so obviously we've got the funeral
on monday and then liz truss is expected
to go to the united nations to new york
for the united nations general assembly
and then to come back in time for this
fiscal event which we're expecting most
likely to be next thursday but it could
be friday um depending on whether the
speaker agrees to push back the start of
the conference recess i think we'll
regardless see the conference recess um
limited at the other end and np's come
back a week earlier than than they were
um they originally planned to do so but
it just it's another example really of
how um
how
the early days of liz truster's new
premiership have been so derailed by the
queen's death and that there's nothing
obviously that
anybody can or would want to do about
that but it is a sort of a as political
watchers as westminster watchers it's
sort of interesting for us to see
um you know we were her big energy
announcement was billed as really sort
of a makeup break moment in which the
tone of her premiership would be set if
she got it right if it landed well then
her mps felt that it would buy her some
more time if it didn't then potentially
that was the beginning of the end of her
her premiership which had barely started
obviously that was all overshadowed by
the queen's death um and then the events
of this week have meant that that
parliament has been suspended
um and that government the business of
government anyway while ongoing is very
sort of low-key and there's not any big
announcements now
liz trust had a sort of a policy plan a
policy blitz for the first few weeks in
power and the number 10 aides have had
to rip that up and start again so this
is the the next big moment if you like
which has been which has been delayed as
a result of of this week um and um
we'll obviously hear as she's promised
throughout the campaign details of her
national insurance cut um the reversal
of the increase in national insurance we
might hear some more about corporation
tax and some other measures to help
support businesses through the economic
storms ahead but what everybody is
really keen to find out is a bit more
detailed about this energy plan because
even though she announced it there was
very little detail on how it would
support for example businesses um or the
public sector schools and hospitals for
example dealing with soaring energy
prices and there was also um very little
detail on how exactly it'd be paid for
so those are some of the questions which
quasi-car telling the chancellor is
going to be expected to answer
in that statement and it's really sort
of the beginning of of a resumption if
you like of politics as normal as
politics as usual after this period of
mourning um so so because of course
while many people feel very profoundly
about the late queen's death and want to
be able to celebrate her life and and
remember that there's also let's not
forget an economic crisis underneath all
of this which um which with many people
struggling with with bills already and
likely to get worse over the winter and
the government will be acutely aware of
the requirements at that point when they
judge that the mood is right um to to
get back to to the really urgent
business at hand
okay and uh really we'll be back to
earth with the bump we've got the uh
bank of england's monetary policy
committee haven't we uh meeting on
thursday week as well and may raise
interest rates by something like 75
basis points uh pippa harry for the time
being thank you very much indeed i know
you're coming back to to join me in the
next hour but